The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So modules,
systems, and reliability.
What we're going to do is talk
about how we go from the cells,
or from the films,
to full modules
and, finally, to systems.
So our first
learning objective is
to describe, more or less, the
DNA or anatomy of a PV module.
This will be a bit of a prep
for the visit to Fraunhofer
CSE, where we'll
get to see the labs
and see all the materials
that go into a PV module.
So just establishing
some definitions
up front so we're all
speaking the same language--
you start out with
either a film.
Right?
If you're depositing
a thin film material,
which is usually divided
into discrete devices
using laser processing,
or you can start out
with a discrete wafer which
has been processed into a cell.
The module is the
combination of many
of these cells, shown
very generically right
here without the interconnects.
Because you can tie
up the cells together
in parallel or in
series, depending
on what sort of voltage
and current outputs
you desire from your module.
And then finally the modules are
situated together in an array.
That's showing a combination
of six modules forming
that array right there.
And as you can see, modules are
typically this size right here.
They're usually about this
size or even a little larger.
They're rather heavy,
so you can get a sense.
They're not extremely light.
The majority of
that mass is coming
from the glass in the front,
some from the aluminum as well.
And they're comprised
of many materials.
If you were to take this
apart-- which we'll actually
see the individual components
at Fraunhofer CSE--
you'll notice that there
are many materials involved
in making one of these modules.
From the back skin
materials, the junction box,
the aluminum framing on the
side, the glass on the front,
the encapsulant materials that
fuse everything together--
that bind everything--
and the cells,
the solar cell
devices themselves.
So our first step is to
walk through the anatomy
of a module, at least in theory,
so that when we actually see it
at Fraunhofer CSE, we'll
have a better sense of what
we're looking at that.
Yeah.
Ashley?
AUDIENCE: Here, what
determines that specific size?
We've already talked
about the pseudo-square
and how you have to balance
those two different cost
parameters.
But why that size specifically?
PROFESSOR: Why that
size specifically?
We're going to get to
that in a few slides.
It comes, as you
probably guessed,
from some historical reasons.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: So some
basic principles
about solar modules-- there's
quite a diversity of modules
when you look at them.
These are examples just
within one company,
just to highlight the
range of module types
that you might see.
Right here, you can see
in this particular module,
there's very little
anti-reflective coating
on the glass.
So you're able to look
through the front glass
and see some white spaces
in between the cells.
We know, from the lecture
on crystalline silicon PV,
that when you see these little
gaps in between the cells,
those are pseudo-squares.
Right?
Those are those round ingots
of Czochralski silicon
that have been
sliced into wafers.
And then the edges
have been shaven off,
and you have that stop sign
type pattern of a solar cell.
Right?
So that way you know, OK, these
are single crystalline cells
lined up in a module together.
And there's very little
anti-reflective coating
on the glass, which
means that you're
losing a fair amount
due to reflectance.
The module on the
right-hand side right
here has that anti-reflection
coating on the glass.
It could be an index
of refraction gradient
to absorb more of the light.
It could also be surface
texturing to scatter the light
and trap it by total internal
reflection once it gets inside.
There's a few different
ways that one can do that.
Usually with a film
coating is the most common.
And here on the
left-hand side, we
have a similar
sub-cell component
but much larger module comprised
of a larger number of cells
with a higher power output.
And we can see quite
a wide variance
of different types of modules.
That will be an important
message in a few.
The water rinse cycle really
depends on where you're at.
For the modules on my roof,
we just leave them up.
Here in New England,
it's pretty much OK.
If we did have trees that
deposited leaves nearby,
we'd have to clean it off
in the fall, but we don't.
If you're mounting
modules in the Middle
East, where that
fine-grained sand exists
and, if you're within 10
kilometers from the coast
where you have the salt and
the seawater in the air,
you can get this really
hard-to-remove sand
caking the modules.
And you would have to clean them
much more frequently than this.
As a matter of fact, I
believe the numbers are--
in Abu Dhabi, the capital of
one of the Emirates in the UAE,
if you were to just leave your
modules out near the ocean,
near the desert, you
would have a 40% drop
in module output over a month.
So that's what happens
in certain environments.
In certain others,
like New England,
we're more buffered
in that regard.
We have frequent rain,
and we don't have the dust
coming from any nearby desert.
Typically, there
are no moving parts,
and typically there's a 20- to
30-year manufacturer warranty.
Some of the newer materials
that have been less tested
might give, say, a 10-year
manufacturer's warranty
and have to offset the
risk in years 10 to 20
by lowering the cost up front
or lowering the price up front.
So we have some basics
about solar modules
just to situate ourselves.
Let's dive into the
module DNA, since this
is where the rubber
hits the road.
I'm going to show
this to you in theory,
and then we're
going to see reams
of these module innard materials
when we visit Fraunhofer.
So we start with the
solar cells themselves.
These are these little
blue objects right there.
Typically, these
cells are already
strung together at that point.
They have contact metallization
on the front side, which
we deposit, say, for example,
by screen printing, which you've
done in the lab downstairs.
And then you string
them together
using a machine called
a tabber-stringer
to connect one cell to the next,
essentially the front of one
cell to the back of the next.
And they're all
lined up like that.
And you deposit layers of EVA,
which is ethyl vinyl acetate.
This is typically the
encapsulant material used.
It's shown in red right
here in this drawing.
It's the encapsulant material
used for crystalline silicon
PV.
On the back side,
there is a sheet
of material called Tedlar.
Despite it being drawn
in yellow right there,
it's the white
skin material here.
It's this white material
right around here.
And we have the glass
on the front side.
And typically,
it's low-iron glass
so it can transmit
the ultraviolet light,
or a large portion of it,
to give better blue response
to your solar cells.
So you're capturing a larger
portion of the solar spectrum.
OK.
So we have the different
components right there.
One little piece of
trivia about EVA--
for the chemists
in the room, what
do you think this
would decompose into?
Let me just give you
a little hand here.
If you had some-- let's see.
All right.
So these represent
methyl groups, hydrogens,
carbon, carbon, carbon,
double bonded to an oxygen.
Anybody recognize?
AUDIENCE: It looks like acetone?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So if you're looking
at the decomposition
of this little group
right here, you
could easily envision it
decomposing into acetic acid
from the name ethyl
vinyl acetate.
So if you have a thin
film material that
could react with
the encapsulant,
you could decompose
your encapsulant
and cause a degradation of not
only the encapsulant itself,
which would block some
of the light going
through, but of the solar
cell absorber material, too.
So that's why, in many
thin film materials,
there are other encapsulants
used, like PVB, polyvinyl
butyral.
And some folks are even
talking about getting away
from glass and EVA
altogether and just
putting down, say, an
organic resin-type material.
Maybe a very hard
polymeric material
that could be used in a floor
in a clean room, let's say.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is the low iron
content of the glass also
important to prevent
all impurities
getting into the silicon
or are we past that point?
PROFESSOR: So the question
was is the low iron
content in the glass also
useful for preventing impurities
from getting in.
I would say, if you're
producing-- the diffusivity
and solubility of
impurities in a solid
typically follow
Boltzmann statistics,
meaning they increase
exponentially with temperature.
It's an entropy-driven effect.
And as a result of being at room
temperature, the transmission,
or the diffusivity and,
hence, the solubility
of iron inside of the
bulk silicon is very low.
And, even over a 20-year span,
the total diffusion length
of the iron from the
glass into the silicon
would be rather small.
Now, point taken, if you
were to, say, create a quartz
tube to do your phosphorus
diffusion at 800 degrees C
or 850 degrees C and you had
iron inside of that quartz
tube, then it could very
easily diffuse into your wafer.
So it is important to be
considerate of impurities
and the effects thereof but
at low temperatures-- close
to room temperature-- there's
very little risk of it
moving around.
Good.
So Tedlar, this back
skin material right here,
forms an almost
impenetrable back layer.
You might want to
put little asterisks
around-- sorry, little
quotes around impenetrable.
Nothing is absolutely
impenetrable
but it is a very
tough, tough material.
If you were to take a piece
of Tedlar and try to break it,
try to rip it or tear it, even
the strongest in the class
would be challenged
in that regard.
And we'll have a chance
to do that at Fraunhofer.
The aluminum frame
provides rigidity.
Right?
So the mechanical
engineers in the room
would understand
that the bending mode
of this glass, or the
twist, is prevented
by these rigid extruded
aluminum components
right here in the back.
And you can see that
a lot of the mass
is concentrated away
from the centroid, which
results in a larger stiffness,
prevention of a larger bending
moment-- second
moment, if you will.
OK.
So there's a fair amount
of mechanical engineering
that goes into the design
because you want to minimize
commodity material costs.
You want to minimize
the amount of materials
that go into the
module, but you still
want it to last for 20 years.
You still want it to be
resistant to snow loads,
to wind loads.
You don't want it
to break, and you
don't want to make good
on your 20-year warranty.
That costs you money
as a manufacturer.
So the circuit design
in most modules
follows something
very similar to this.
Now, what you see when
you glance at this,
what you should be looking at
is-- here are the contacts.
Those are the leads
coming out of the module.
They're essentially
these leads coming out
in the back of the junction box.
If you want to turn it
around again, here we go.
So here are the module
leads coming out.
And the question is,
how do I string together
the cells inside of my module?
How do I string together
these cells right in here
to provide the greatest
value to the customer?
Do I connect them all in
series and make just one
long, snaky electronic path?
Do I connect them
all in parallel?
But that would require
a lot of wiring.
Do I do something in between?
And if you were to
come up close to here
and inspect it,
what you would see
is that you have
strings in parallel.
So you have one going from
here, down and around.
That's one, two, and three.
Right?
Three of these
strings, and they're
connected-- those three strings
are connected in parallel.
Each string is comprised
of several solar cells.
Now, for historical reasons, the
crystalline silicon solar cell
modules have typically had
strings of around 36 cells
connected in series.
What this does is it yields
a maximum power point
voltage somewhere in the
range of 17 to 18 volts.
If you remember the
VOCs of your solar cells
and that maximum power point,
the voltage of your solar cells
are some around 0.5.
And so you take 36 cells,
divide by 2-- or multiply
by 0.5, if you will.
And you're landing
somewhere in this ballpark.
And what that does is it enables
you to hit, even under lower
light conditions,
the overpotential
needed to charge a
rechargeable battery.
So if there's a 12-volt
battery and the voltage output
of the battery is
between, say, 12
and kind of dropping down
to 10 before it starts
using its utility-- when
you try to start your car
and it doesn't really turn over
and you can start your engine,
it's probably because the
voltage in your battery
has dropped to about 10 volts.
The overpotential needed
to charge it, 13-plus,
that's what you're
hitting with the string.
And that's, for
historical reasons,
why we had this number of
cells connected together.
As grid-tied systems
become more common,
though, this constraint
is being reduced.
Over 90% of all of
our solar modules
today are connected to the grid,
including the ones in my home.
So when I'm not there and it's
producing excess electricity,
it's pumping it into the grid.
And maybe we're using
some of my electrons here.
I don't know.
So as grid-tied systems
become more common,
you care less about meeting
the overpotential requirements
for a battery.
You care more about matching
the output of your solar module
with whatever inverter
technology you're
using to convert the
DC power into AC power.
Number two, why do they
spec the modules that size?
You notice that I could
lift it, just barely.
I'm a university professor.
I sit in my chair and
think most of the time.
A person, somebody strong out
there in the field mounting
modules, say if Jessica in the
back were a module installer,
she could lift this no problem
probably with her pinky finger.
And that's why they're
bite-sized, right?
They're a single-person,
liftable, installable modules.
You can't make them
too big, or else you
start needing cranes which, of
course, has its own benefits
for large field installations.
Wouldn't really make sense
with our current mode
of installation on residential.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: If you had a
battery-- if you were charging
a battery with the module,
you also wouldn't want
to have too many volts, right?
Maybe that's a really
basic electronics question.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
the question is, do you
benefit by having
larger overpotential
when recharging a battery?
Well, I'm not a battery
expert, so I'll definitely
caution on this.
I would imagine that there
would be some law of diminishing
returns.
You would be limited in
terms of the recharge rate,
not by the overpotential
but by some other component
like the electrolyte
diffusivity,
let's say, inside of your
system-- as an example.
But I would defer that
to the battery experts.
My impression, though,
is that you get
a law of diminishing returns.
Packing fraction in the modules.
So we talked about the
different cell sizes
if you're processing
discrete cells.
The higher packing fraction
enables lower glass encapsulant
and cost per watt peak.
The lower packing
fraction, you get
to play some games with
optical concentration.
For here, for instance, if you
have space between your cells,
you can have a diffuse
Lambertian scatterer
in the back which will reflect
the light at a different angle,
scattering it.
And that light could be trapped
by total internal reflection
inside of the glass if the
angle reaching the glass
is, say, 15 degrees or greater.
So you can play
some games there.
That's why the Tedlar
back skin being white
is typically used in most solar
modules, so that we reflect
and then scatter and
then trap the light that
comes in in between the cells.
So to put this into
another fancier,
three-dimensional framework-- we
have our interconnected cells.
We have our encapsulant
above and below.
The encapsulant material
is an interesting thing.
It's solid at room
temperature but it
begins to flow at
around 150, 175 degrees
C which means, if
you've ever put
a plastic bottle in the oven
and you've noticed how it begins
to melt and sag and
droop, that's essentially
the type of flow that you
would experience inside
of this encapsulant material.
And it flows around the cells.
And it fuses them together
with the glass on top,
and they stick together
once they cool down
to room temperature.
That forms what's
called a laminate.
Because now you
have the back skin--
the frame isn't
shown right here--
you have the back skin material.
You have the
encapsulant, the cells,
the encapsulant
on the other side,
and your glass on the front
side all together forming
a nice stack of materials.
And they're stuck together,
or bound, by the encapsulant.
That's called a laminate.
It doesn't resist bending
very well, or twist very well,
because it doesn't yet
have the frame on it.
But it certainly can be
transported around the factory
and moved from one
station to another
without risk of, say,
the cells falling out.
They're pretty well fused there.
In terms of moving
to new materials,
there's a lot of work right now
to squeeze the commodity costs
out of solar module
manufacturing.
If you look at the percentage
of cost of commodity materials
in the solar module,
it is quite high.
And so people are focusing
on new types of transparent
front surface materials
that let the light in,
glass replacements.
Right?
You could envision--
we have many examples
of really hard, resistant,
polymeric materials
in our daily lives.
People are looking into those.
The encapsulant materials--
ethyl vinyl acetate
is fairly expensive, and there
aren't that many companies
that manufacture it.
And so people are looking
to options to replace it.
Tedlar even more so,
that back skin material.
Although the challenge there
is a lot harder, a lot tougher.
No pun intended.
It's a really strong material.
And a lot of our modern
chemistry or chemical
engineering goes into
making and designing it.
And then finally finding some
replacement for the frame.
People are talking
about frameless modules.
That means taking off
this aluminum piece
right here on the side and
just leaving the laminate
and somehow providing
the mechanical rigidity
to the laminate and avoiding the
cost of the extruded aluminum
components.
So a lot of work going
in in module design.
This is a picture of folks
mounting the aluminum framing
onto the module.
These are essentially
large steel components
that are pushing the
aluminum into the module
and making sure that there's a
snug fit between the aluminum
and the module itself.
As you can see by the size
and shapes of these cells,
that gives you an indication
of what company that is.
Module technology--
there's some work as well
going into
replacing-- let's see,
here we go-- replacing the
tabbing-stringing step.
Right?
So this is a machine
the tabs and strings
the cells to one another.
We'll see one at Fraunhofer.
It's really impressive
when you see it go,
but it's also quite expensive.
And so if you could get rid
of the tabbing stringing--
imagine just lining
up the little cells
like cookies on a cookie sheet.
And they all are interconnected
by contact with whatever back
skin material is on the
back that is printed,
let's say, with the
circuitry already.
You would wind up in
a situation like this,
where you have your
cells in direct contact
with some printed
circuitry on your back.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom--
and you're off and running.
In this particular case, you see
these little white dots here.
The grid pattern on that cell
is a radial spiderweb pattern
that emanates from
that central point,
collects current from
nearby-- essentially,
an area about that
big is collected,
let's say by that little
point right there.
And then there's a hole drilled
through the solar cell where
the metal is wrapping
through to the back.
And that's where it's making
contact with the back side
right there.
And there are other
regions of the solar cell
that are making contact with
the bulk, the base, if you will.
So you have both of your
n- and your p-type contacts
on the back side
of your solar cell.
And that's what's
shown in this drawing.
So there are attempts, as
well, to put all the contacts,
or connect the
contacts, onto the back
to enable this
monolithic manufacturing.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How does
that not short?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how is that not a short?
Let me show you how that
would not be a short.
What I'm going to do is attempt
to draw two different cell
designs that could
lead to not shorting.
One cell design that
could lead to not shorting
would be-- let's say this
would be our front surface.
Our base is-- I'm going
to draw it flat here
in the back just for
simplicity, but it
could be textured as well.
I'm going to call this a lightly
doped semiconductor material.
And then I could
have heavily doped--
let's say this would be--
I'm going to exaggerate
here just for effect.
This could be my heavily
n-type doped material.
p-type doped material.
So I'm drawing p plus, n plus,
another n plus, another p plus.
So I have charge separation
occurring at these regions
right here and then
contacts on the other side.
This is my electron contact.
This is my hole contact.
And now what's happening
is photoexcited carriers
are being generated in here.
But the field that separates
them is all in the back.
And so now the carriers
are being separated,
electrons being collected by
the darker-shaded, rather,
the shaded areas,
and the holes being
collected by these unshaded
contacts here in the back.
And, if I'm clever about
my contact positioning,
here I have kind of an
interdigitated electron
and hole collectors.
Right?
I'm able to collect both without
having any sort of shunting.
Another design might
be-- let's see.
So this is called an
Interdigitated Back Contact
structure, or IBC.
AUDIENCE: What is
it, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Actually,
less relevant
in this particular case.
In most interdigitated
back contact cells,
it's actually n-type silicon,
lightly doped n-type silicon,
just because point defects tend
to have smaller capture cross
sections than n-type
silicon and p-type silicon.
So minority carrier
lifetime tends to be larger.
Another cell design, again,
looking at cross section,
you might have-- this
being your solar cell--
you could add texture,
but I'm omitting it just
for simplicity.
Now, let's see, we drill a
hole using a laser right here.
So we have a very thin hole.
Of course, in three
dimensions, there's
mechanical rigidity by
the bulk of the material
in the other dimension.
But we have this hole
drilled through--
and we can make about 18,000
of these holes in about
six seconds with modern
laser technology,
so it's really not that
hard to make this happen.
Although a lot of engineering
effort is put into it,
but it is possible.
And then you could have your
contact metallization, say,
for electrons right here.
You could have the p-n
junction like this.
So this, here, could be
your n plus material.
Again, n plus material, this,
by effect, would also be.
And you can have your
p materials over here.
And you could make
contact to the back right
here and contact to
the back right here.
And as long as there's no metal
short between the electron
and hole-- say, for example, you
generate an electron hole pair
here, the electron
goes up to here.
It goes through the metal to
the back and gets pulled out.
And the hole goes to
this contact over here,
and that's how you
separate the charges.
So this would be an example
of an emitter wrap through
or a metal wrap through
device technology.
Also shown-- MWT,
Metal Wrap Through.
So we have at least two
different device geometries
and many more device
architectures that could fit in
with this future vision.
The problem right now is that
the printed back skin materials
cost about five times more
than the non-printed ones
just because they're
very low scale.
People haven't
investigated it much.
So any time you introduce
a new technology
into the market-- you'll
hear it over and over again
in these innovation and
entrepreneurship classes here
at MIT-- you have to
be significantly better
than the competition.
If you're only a
little bit better,
you face an enormous
barrier to entry
because you have the rest of
the industry pedaling along
on their bicycles
in a huge peloton,
benefiting from each
other's drafting,
and you're on your own bike
facing your own headwinds.
Right?
Trying to build everything
up-- your own factory,
your own expertise.
It's challenging.
But I'm not trying to put
a damper on innovation.
I'm just trying to qualify the
areas of greatest opportunity
and lowest resistance to change.
Go ahead, prove me wrong.
Make a difference.
Without that sort of
headstrong mentality of,
gosh, I know I
have something here
and I'm just going to prove
the world that I have it,
we wouldn't have, for example,
the Pilkington plate glass
process working-- or float
glass process, sorry.
We'd still probably be pouring
and grinding and polishing
our panes of glass and
they'd be very expensive.
That was a little side story,
but it took them about 10 years
to develop the
float glass process
inside of a company
owned by a family,
as opposed to a
publicly traded company.
So they could
continue losing money
over a long period of time
until they perfected it.
And once they got it right,
the whole world copied it,
but it took 10 years
of good investment
for them to get it right.
All right.
Let's move on.
We're going to talk about
module spec sheets here.
When you came into
class today, you
should have picked
up one of these.
This is an example of a First
Solar module spec sheet.
What it does is it hits
you front and center.
The company name-- First Solar.
FS Series 3-- that's the name
of the module, and PV module.
So it gives you the
mechanical description,
the size, the weight.
And then, on the
back, it gives you
all of the technical
parameters that you've wanted.
So on the backside
of the-- we'll
go to the First
Solar spec sheet.
OK.
Well, on your spec
sheet right here, you
can look at some
of the parameters.
There's power at the
maximum power point,
voltage and current at
the maximum power point,
the VOC, the ISC, and so forth.
You have a bunch of different
parameters including
the temperature sensitivity.
Right?
How much does the power degrade
with increasing temperature?
So all of these things
we've studied in class,
and now when you pick up
the spec sheet you're a pro.
You look at it, and
you're like, oh yeah.
I know what that does.
I know what that means.
I know how to model the
energy output of the system.
And that's essentially what the
engineers do when they pick up
the spec sheet.
They read it.
And then they input those
parameters into their computer
models, and they can predict how
these modules will perform out
in the field at
a given location.
OK.
And so you have a variety
of different spec sheets.
These are the modules
that are on my roof.
They're Sharp 187-watt modules.
You have, for example,
right here an example
of an Evergreen Solar module.
Let's spend a minute here
looking a little more deeply.
These modules, these
Evergreen Solar modules,
are the same size, but there are
three different power outputs.
And I think we went
through this already.
We have good cells, medium
cells and bad cells.
And they're binned together
in the different modules
so that they can extract
the maximum price
from the consumer.
So that's why you have the
three different ratings of power
for three different
types of modules
with, essentially, the same
form factor, the same size
and weight.
They're just
different-quality cells.
Yeah.
So that's that.
Temperature
coefficients, so forth.
OK.
One thing to note right
here is, on the back sides
of your modules, you typically
have a little diagram that
shows you how to interconnect
one module to the next.
And those are the
cables that are
used to do the interconnection.
There are some companies
trying to get fancy right now
and saying, well, instead
of interconnecting and then
affixing the modules
separately, why don't we
just make these modules
that kind of click together?
And part of the clicking
process is the interconnection
electrically, and the
other part, obviously,
is the mechanical rigidity.
So there's certainly room for
optimization on module design.
Yeah.
Jessica.
AUDIENCE: When they're
sold-- when modules are sold,
they're advertised for their
voltage at maximum power point,
right?
PROFESSOR: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: What's a software that
we should use-- I'm actually
using this for another class.
What's the software that we
should use that maximum power
point voltage into-- translate
that into what it's actually
going to be? [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the question became how do
I go from a module spec sheet,
like this, with this
data right here,
and translate that into number
of kilowatt hours produced
per unit time-- day, year--
at a given site location.
The best program that I know
of that encompasses all of this
would be a program called
PVWatts, produced by NREL.
PVWatts, all together,
and you can look it up,
you can use it
online, and you can
input your specific module spec
parameters into the program.
Now, that said, we
have a lot of the tools
to do the estimates ourselves.
If you ruffle back
to homework-- I
think it was
homework number two,
we calculated the
output of a solar system
based on the module
spec parameters.
And so now that we can
pick up a module spec sheet
and read it in a
bit more detail,
we can perform those estimates
a little bit more accurately.
Yep.
Omar.
AUDIENCE: Your first solar
panel is a lot smaller
than that panel right there?
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So is there a
reason why First Solar
goes with smaller cells?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
So why is this First Solar
module, the FS Series 3 module,
a little smaller than some
of the crystalline silicon
modules?
For thin film
deposition, especially
for this closed-space
sublimation process
that First Solar
uses, you're limited
in terms of the deposition area
by the uniformity of deposition
over a large region.
So if you're sputtering
the material,
it's typically
related to the size
of your target and the
distance to your substrate.
That will limit the maximum size
that you can deposit uniformly.
And you probably want to deposit
within plus or minus 2%, let's
say.
Maybe 5%.
I'm not extremely privy to the
precise tolerances in the PV
industry in terms of thin
film thickness variation,
but that would be my estimate.
And in terms of these thermal
evaporation processes,
again, it's how the
machine is designed.
So I imagine you could
probably go bigger.
Is it cost effective?
Question mark.
Somebody at First Solar most
obviously did the cost analysis
and said that this is the
optimum between a variety
of different factors, between
manufacturability and ease
of installation.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is there any reason
why they don't put efficiency
on this sheet?
PROFESSOR: Is there a reason
why they don't put efficiency
on the sheet?
Well, you could
probably very easily
calculate the efficiency, right?
There are two types of
module efficiencies.
There is what's called
total area efficiency, where
you take the total
area of your module
all the way up to
the aluminum frame
and calculate that as your area.
So you take your power--
your maximum power
rated at AM 1.5 sun conditions
and divide it by the area.
There's also a variety of
other less straightforward ways
of calculating
efficiency, some of which
take the active area
of the cells only.
Others exclude the frame.
And so the module efficiency is
not extremely straightforward
parameter.
It has to be specified based
on what areas is assumed.
That would be my
estimate for why they
didn't put it right on here.
And secondly, their module
efficiency, if you do the math,
that one probably turns out
to be somewhere between 11%
and 11.5%.
Now they're hitting 12% or so.
That's not a very high
number compared to, say,
a crystalline silicon module.
And so it wouldn't be
probably something they
advertise in their spec sheet.
Describe how PV module
power output is affected
by the cell mismatch losses.
Warning-- I'm going to
lose some of you on this.
Those of you without a very
strong electrical engineering
or physics background,
I'm going to pick you up
at point number three, so
plant a flag right here.
We'll come back to it.
But for those who
care to follow along,
this is some really
fun stuff that
can get into why we want
to match our cells properly
in terms of their outputs.
So the total current
output-- this
is the ideal diode
equation without all
the fancy two-diode
model, recombination
of the space charge region,
recombination of the bulk,
without the series resistance
and shunt resistance.
Just a very simple explanation
of this ideal diode model.
What we're doing is our M is
the number of cells in parallel
and our N is the number
of cells in series.
So we go back to our
equivalent circuit diagrams
where we have two voltage
current sources that
are connected in series.
If you connect
those two in series,
now the voltages will add.
So the effective voltage
across the entire system,
if you draw a black box around
your two individual voltage
producers, the effective
voltage across the entire system
will be voltage 1 plus
voltage 2, in series.
The currents-- now, if you
think about the current,
you can think of current--
the first order--
as a river of electrons trying
to flow through your circuit.
If there's any
bottleneck somewhere,
that's going to limit
the current that can flow
through the entire circuit.
So the combined
current is going to be
limited by the worst performer.
In mathematical terms, it
would be the harmonic mean.
1 over effective current
would be 1 over current 1
plus 1 over current 2.
So what we see here is, if
we have a number of cells
connected in
parallel-- now, instead
of having them connected
in series like this,
you connect them in parallel--
now the currents are adding.
And the voltage will be
limited by the worst performer.
Because the
potential across both
is going to be
limited by whatever
the lowest potential is.
So when we connect in
parallel, we add currents.
And when we connect in
series, we add voltages.
That's a very simple
way to think about it,
and that's why we have the
M appearing here up top.
If you have a number of
cells connected in parallel,
you will essentially
be multiplying
the [? illuminated ?] current
of one cell by whatever M it is.
And if you have a number of
cells connected in series,
that will impact the voltage.
OK.
So that's an expression
that is useful for N and M
number of identical cells
connected in either series
or parallel, respectively.
And in practice, if we have
bad performers in the bunch,
if we have one cell
that's performing worse
than another, either because
it is intrinsically worse--
it is a defective cell
that somehow got in there
or became defective during use--
or it's a temporary effect.
Maybe a seagull just
landed on top of that cell
and is shading it.
Right?
So whatever the reason is--
temporary or permanent--
that cell number 2,
now, is a bad apple.
And so if we're looking
at parallel mismatches,
we take what we know
about cells in parallel.
OK.
The voltage is limited
by the worst performer.
And we look at the
individual IV curves
of the good and the bad cell.
This is the good cell right
here, this curve there.
Right?
And so this, now,
is positive power.
Essentially, power coming
out of the solar cell
is plotted in the
first quadrant.
We have a lot of
power coming out
and a large voltage
for our good cell.
Here's our bad cell right there.
So slightly lower
current outputs
given by the logarithmic effect.
And the voltage is lower,
significantly lower,
than, say, the good cell.
And so the combined
output right here,
the current at short
circuit current conditions,
is going to be the sum
of the good and the bad.
So that's there.
The voltage is going to be
the harmonic mean, so limited
by the worst performer.
That's how low-voltage
cells can really
mess up parallel strings.
So for example, this set
of two rows of cells,
this one right here, which
is all connected in series.
It's connected in parallel
to this one and this one.
And so if one of these
three subsets of cells
has a lower voltage
than the others,
the combined voltage
output of the entire module
will be lower.
Similarly, now we've
put them in series,
if we have a bad
cell that's producing
less current than the
good cell-- and notice
that they're saying
open circuit voltage now
just for the thought experiment
here in the classroom.
Typically, if a cell is
performing worse than current,
it will also have
a lower voltage.
But just for the thought
experiment right here,
we have bad cell, good cell.
Bad cell has about half the
current of the good cell.
So the voltage output
in series is going
to be the addition of the two.
Boom, boom.
Then you're up to here.
But the current output will be
limited by the worst performer.
And again, the combined
output of this set
of cells connected in series is
going to be right around here.
And so based on your
cell performance--
if you know that
your voltage has
a certain variance in
your manufacturing line
and your current has a certain
variance in your manufacturing
line, that might entice
you to string together
your cells in one
way or another,
depending on how you want
to mitigate your losses.
Shaded cells-- so up to
now, everybody kind of
gets based on Kirchhoff's
laws and so forth
from equivalent circuit
diagrams, so we're rolling.
Now we're going to
get the shaded cells.
And here's where it
becomes a little bit more
difficult to understand
absent the reading
in that book over there.
Did everybody get a chance
to see the blue book?
Did it make its
rounds over here?
No, it didn't.
Why don't we pass
the blue book around?
Omar over there didn't get
a chance to see it yet.
We're going to
consider that we have
10 identical solar cells
connected in series,
and this one over
here is shaded.
What happens now?
So this is described, I believe,
in figure 5.7 in the book, one
with the green little tab.
We've assumed that the
combined IV characteristic
of the n good cells
is this one right here
and the one bad cell
is this right here.
So it's a little bit of a
strange IV characteristic.
And what happens next?
If you combine the two in series
and you use the same protocol
that we've done so far,
the voltage will add.
So whatever voltage gain right
here has been added over here.
But the current is
going to be limited
by the worst performer,
which happens to be
this solar cell right here.
And so the combined
output is going
to be lower-- significantly
lower-- than those
of the good cells.
And that's what happens
when one cell in a string
is shaded if there aren't any
fancy electronics to allow
the current to bypass it.
Furthermore, this
amount of power
will be dissipated
in the bad cell when
the string is short circuited.
It can change a bit when you
start moving toward operating
conditions, but it's a
sizable amount of power being
dumped into that bad cell.
And in practice, that
cell is reverse biased.
Let me show you using
our wonderful PV
CD-ROM exactly why that is.
So here we have two solar
cells connected in series.
And they're both producing
an equal amount of current
because they have an equal
number of these yellow arrows
incident on them.
And they're equal in
every other aspect.
So it's still a thought
experiment right now.
The current that is cycling
through this circuit,
in the external
circuit right here--
the magnitude of that current
is being indicated by the color.
And, in this particular
case, it's very bright.
It's bright green.
It indicates a lot of current
is flowing through it.
So, up to now,
everything makes sense.
This is in short
circuit conditions,
so there's no voltage.
There's no potential
across either cell.
It's in short
circuit conditions,
and current is flowing through
this circuit right here.
Now I'm going to
mismatch the two cells.
I'm going to exchange one of
the cells for a bad apple.
OK.
First off, I know,
just from what
we've been talking about so
far that the current is limited
by the worst performer,
that the current flowing
through the external circuit
is now going to be lower.
And the first order-- it's more
or less approximate to what
the current is in this bad cell.
So the bad cell
right here, which
is indicated by the two arrows
now instead of the four,
this shaded cell right here
is producing less current.
And so I know, based on
what we've talked about
so far, that the
combined current output
of the entire circuit is going
to be approximately this one.
So hence you see a
darker color represented,
the same color that's
flowing through the cell.
So what happens to
the large amount
of current that's being
generated inside of this one?
That cell still has
the capacity to produce
a large amount of current.
Where is it going?
Well, some of that current is
going through this cell right
here, forward biasing
it, which would
result in a negative bias, or
reverse bias, of the bad cell.
Because the potential
across this combined system
still has to be zero.
You're in short
circuit conditions,
so the potential here has to be
equal to the potential there.
So what I've effectively
done is I've reverse
biased my bad cell.
And we'll get to why
that's a problem later on.
Those who are
electrical engineers
can already begin
conjuring up ideas
of reverse biased breakdown.
We'll explain why reverse
bias is bad in a few.
Now, if you had a series
of these cells connected--
a bunch of these cells
connected in series--
and they were all producing
copious amounts of juice,
and you had one bad
apple in your string,
you would be dumping a
considerable amount of power
across that.
Or you could be dumping a
considerable amount of power
across that one cell.
And that's where
this graph right here
comes from, the power
dissipated within the bad cell.
And that's a problem
because if there's
any weakness in the p-n
junction of that bad cell
and you're reverse
biasing it, you're
going to be flooding
a lot of current
through that one
little spot, which
means that that spot's
going to heat up.
And it's going to form a hot
spot, which has the potential
to get very hot.
And we know that the
encapsulant materials
flow at around 150
to 175 degrees C,
and some other material
failures can occur above that.
So hot spots are bad.
If you reverse
bias your devices,
you can enter what's called
a breakdown regime that,
essentially, is
driven, oftentimes,
in a real solar cell by isolated
points and your weaknesses
in the p-n junction where
current is going to flow.
And that leads to the hot
spot failure I just mentioned.
Here's thermographic imaging--
not using the fancy camera
that we have downstairs, using
a much simpler camera out
in the field, lower cost.
These are high enough
temperature variances
to be able to detect using
pretty low-tech technology.
It's not a small
amount of current
going through a solar cell.
These are large, massive
amounts of current
going through defective
cells in the field.
And so you can use these
cameras to visualize
the underperforming
cells inside of modules.
Now, that's pretty nifty.
All right.
So we planted that flag,
and let's come back to it.
We're going to describe
how microinverters
and microelectronics can improve
module performance output.
Even if you didn't follow
all the detailed explanation
until now, you can
appreciate the fact
that a bad apple or bad
solar cell, connected
in series or in parallel
with the rest of them,
can cause the combined output
of the module to be lower.
And so we're going to talk
about how microelectronics
and eventually microinverters
can help resolve that,
either on a cell level or on a
larger module-to-module level.
The simple principle of a
bypass diode of a cell is this.
If the reverse bias
current becomes too large,
instead of forcing the current
to flow through the bad cell,
you can force it to flow
around a bypass diode.
And therefore, it
short circuits--
it leaves the cell
out of the circuit.
Right?
The current is
flowing around it,
and so you result in less of
a degradation of your module.
To put it from an equivalent
IV curve perspective,
instead of adding this IV curve
here with the rest of them,
you're simply moving
the current around it
so you would have the n
good cells, and that's it.
End of story.
The 10th cell would just be
taken out of your circuit.
It would be pushed aside.
OK.
So on a cell level,
that make sense.
Let's skip over a couple
of these, I think.
On a module level, as well,
it can make a lot of sense.
And here, it really
does because the shading
losses on a module level
tend to be more severe.
You can have, for example,
a tree in the wrong place
or a telephone pole
somewhere, shading
one particular module in an
array, an array of modules.
On my roof, for example,
there are 12 Sharp 187s.
So if you have a series of
these modules up on the roof,
you can cause the
current to circumvent
one of the modules that's
underperforming, again,
using the bypass diodes.
And those are fairly standard
in most of the junction boxes.
So inside of here, there is
some very simple electronics
to prevent the modules
from becoming power sinks
and perhaps even drawing
power from the grid.
OK.
So microinverters--
some people say, well,
instead of just managing
power on a DC basis
and either dealing
with the mismatch loss
or cutting bad apples out
of the circuit altogether,
let's do something even better.
Let's try to-- to put this in
childhood education terms--
let's let every module perform
up to their greatest potential,
and then everybody is happy.
Right?
So we're going to convert
the power directly
on the back of the module
into AC, alternating current.
And then we're going to
use electronics from there
to essentially add
the currents together
once we have defined
the voltage at 120 volts
at alternating current.
And the advantage of that
is that if one module is
underperforming, instead
of contributing zero,
it's now contributing
some fraction.
If the mismatch was small enough
not to trip any of the bypass
diodes but still degrade the
power of the overall system,
now you're able to
recover-- you're
able to allow that good
module to perform up
to its true potential
instead of being dragged down
by the others.
And so the
microinverter companies
that are proposing, and
actually marketing and selling,
modules that apply the
electronics directly
in the back of the
solar panels have
the advantage of
being able to eke out
several additional percent of
total power from the array,
from the system.
The disadvantage of distributing
these microinverter components
over every single module is?
AUDIENCE: You have to make a lot
of them, and they cost money.
PROFESSOR: You have
to make a lot of them.
They cost money.
They're costly, and-- mean
time between failures?
Increases.
Right?
Potentially.
So if you have an
inverter-- how many people
know how long an inverter
lasts before it needs
to be replaced, typically?
5 to 10 years.
Now it's up to, say,
7 to 12, but yes.
Somewhere in that range.
Less than the 20- to 30-year
life span of your array.
So now if you have these
distributed little inverters
across every solar
panel and they fizz out
after a certain amount
of time, somebody
has to go up there
and replace them.
First, identify where they went
down and then replace them.
So microinverter longevity
is an important part
of reducing risk and
marketing inverters.
So the microinverter community
is helping to push, or improve,
the quality of inverters over
the entire solar spectrum,
which is kind of cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What's
the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: So, my understanding
from Rajeev Ram, who
is actually down in
ARPA-E right now--
he's a professor at MIT
who's been assisting
the DOE over the past
couple of years-- most
failure in inverters relates
to the power electronics itself
and the high speed
switchers that are used.
That's my understanding.
I could look into
that a little bit more
and get you more details about
precise inverter failure modes,
but that is my
rudimentary understanding
from discussions with him.
Sorry, my screen
is still cracked.
It's going to be fixed tonight.
Advantages of integrated
power electronics
is maximum power point tracking.
This advantage is-- OK.
Yep.
OK.
And so it's still a
relatively hot topic.
There was an ARPA-E call for
improved power electronics
across solar and
other industries.
And there is some discussion
in the PV community
as to how much to adopt this
new technology, especially
in residential systems.
So trends in
installations in general.
In the past, installations
were heavily labor-intensive.
There is now a large
amount of pre-assembly
done before the
modules hit the roof,
but there's still
a sizable number
of components that go into
every single solar module.
And that takes time, to
mount everything out there
in the field.
So what are some other--
what is the dream
of any solar installer?
Is to get this roll of
material just unrolls, unfurls,
onto the roof and using a staple
gun-- bang, bang, bang, bang,
bang-- or a nail gun.
Everything is locked down.
It's lightweight.
It doesn't underperform
when it gets too warm.
These are all the specs
that would constitute, say,
an ideal solar module.
We don't get that lucky.
We have to make
compromises in reality.
Say, for example,
on my roof there
was a soft spot on the roof
that had to be worked around.
The structural engineer
had to be called back
and evaluate and figure out
whether or not it needed
reinforcements and so forth.
So we're still far
away in terms of where
we need to be for
solar installations
to really be truly low cost.
And a lot of it has to do with
the balance of system design.
So I mentioned a few
companies are attempting
to integrate the connections
into this facile click-lock
mechanism.
There have been patents filed, I
think, since the 1990s on this.
Probably even earlier.
More recently, some
companies have marketed
a product in this regard.
And of course, that increases
the facility of installation.
There's even a few
that are selling,
I think, it was Akeena at
Lowe's and, for a time,
BP Solar was selling
at Home Depot.
They're examples of
companies beginning
to market their product
at hardware stores.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Could you
define exactly what
you mean by balance of systems?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So balance of systems
is defined as everything
beyond the module.
So that would include
the wiring, the framing,
the racking, the inverter.
Yes.
That is balance of systems.
Excellent question.
So we're going to talk
about some of the tests
that the PV module
must pass to ensure
reliable multi-decade
service life in the field
and some of the
shortcomings of the tests.
I'm going to motivate
this by saying
there's reason to be
concerned, in the early days
of the industry, about
performance and reliability.
This was a study done
by Arne Jacobson.
The group that's working
with the World Bank
will be as well working with
Arne Jacobson on the class
project.
He's a professor at Humboldt
University in California.
During his PhD with
Dan Kammen in Berkeley,
he did an audit of rated
versus actual power
outputs of solar modules in
the field of Kenya in Africa
and found a rather
large discrepancy
between what was promised and
what was actually delivered.
This is a great example
of field work being
done-- good old-fashioned
detective work-- that leads
to changes in the industry.
That got a number of
the under-performers
to improve their product.
So I mentioned there's a
question of the customer.
Am I getting the real value
that I've been promised?
Especially in the absence
of independent monitoring.
If you're not actively
measuring the power output
and recording it, there's
always that question lingering.
So module testing
and reliability
is meant to ensure product
quality and output quality.
Secondly, it's safety.
I mentioned that these
thermographic cameras-- this
is an example in an
array, of a hot spot.
It's not too hot right now.
It's 36 degrees or so,
but everything else
is down around 15.
If you imagine this being
on a sunny day-- a really
sunny day-- this
hot spot potentially
could be getting up much higher.
So that's obviously of concern.
And there's as well
hot spots or heat
that can be generated from
the junction box on the back.
This contains a fair amount
of electronics, again.
And if there is some failure of
the electronics inside of here,
you can have the combined power
output of the entire module
arcing through a given
component back here causing
sparks to fly.
And this is where this Photon
International article from 2009
comes in where they say
it's extremely important--
the upshot of the
entire article,
I gave it to you
in its entirety.
But the upshot is let's
not play with fire,
meaning let's make
sure that the safety
standards of solar modules
are really up to spec
so that the risk of something
catastrophically bad happening
is negligible.
Because there's nothing
worse for a nascent industry
than to have some,
dare I say it,
Fukushima equivalent occur on
some very high-profile event
that causes public opinion
to sway against it.
So making sure that
modules are safe
is of utmost importance
to preserving
the positive image of solar.
And that's what this article
here is meant to convey,
and you're welcome
to read it in detail.
It cites one particular example
where that didn't happen
and it did lead to it a little
PR event-- well-justified,
in fact.
Shown here are a series
of tests that one
can conduct with solar modules.
I showed a list of different IEC
tests, standardized protocols.
These are a series of tests,
typically between 12 and 20,
that represent a battery of
tests for the solar module.
And if they pass it,
they are IEC certified.
And you'll see on the back
of certain spec sheets,
like this one from
First Solar right here,
the different testing agencies
that have certified the module,
these little logos represented.
So it says it's UL
certified, CE mark,
certified according
to IEC spec 61646.
That's the one right up there
at the top and so forth.
So certification
is very important.
What happens during testing?
Well, we'll see it because when
I designed the Fraunhofer CSE
labs, we designed it, Roland
Schindler and I, with the IEC
tests in mind.
So each of the
pieces of equipment
out there are to test one
component of the IEC test.
Included in the test is
environmental cycling,
where you take a
module, stick it inside
of what looks like an oven.
And it heats it up, cools
it down, heats it up,
cools it down or maintains
a high temperature
with high humidity.
Different types of environmental
chambers do different things,
but they're meant to simulate
an accelerated aging process.
Again, since most
diffusion processes
are driven by
Boltzmann statistics,
there's an exponential increase
with increasing temperature.
And hence, we can simulate
accelerated degradation
at higher temperatures.
So it's not uncommon
that you hear
about 85/85 tests,
which mean 85 degrees
Celsius at 85% humidity.
So that is a massive jungle.
We don't have, thankfully,
places on earth like that.
The maximum temperatures
are at around 45, 50,
55 degrees C typically and,
in those cases, very dry.
But in here, 85
degrees Celsius--
it's still below the
boiling point of water.
Very high humidity
and the humidity,
if there is any place for the
humidity go inside the module,
if you have any failure of
your encapsulant material
or it can get inside, it will.
And it will begin
degrading your module.
You'll see the power
output decrease.
And after three months subjected
to that sort of torture,
if the module is poorly
designed, oftentimes
it will fail.
Now, some of the
shortcomings of these
tests-- that
humidity cycle isn't
necessarily, with the module,
experiencing an applied bias
voltage.
So if there's any
electromigration affect,
you might not
detect it with that.
So there are people
designing new forms
of tests that will
probe other failure
modes, other degradation
mechanisms, that
aren't necessarily captured
in these IEC tests.
Do you have a question?
No.
No question.
OK.
Yeah.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: What is the failure
mode of degradation by water?
PROFESSOR: By water?
Yes.
So water, humidity--
typically what happens
is, in the laminate
itself, there
will be some part at the
edge that water can get in.
Not always, but in the
poorly designed ones,
yes, and so the water
can get in and begin
diffusing into the module.
So if you have a thin
film material that
reacts with water, you might
degrade the actual absorber
layer itself.
If you have a silicon
device, the water
could react with
the metal and cause
it to corrode-- cause it
to oxidize, in other words.
And of course, in reacting
with the ethyl vinyl acetate,
it can cause the encapsulant
to delaminate from the cells
and tear apart.
And so you see this
discoloration of the module.
Those are some of
the failure modes
that can occur when water
gets in through the side.
If it managed to
permeate the encapsulant
materials themselves,
those sorts of effects
can occur directly as opposed
to coming in through the sides.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: So they presumably
test some small fraction
of the modules.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: That they [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yep.
So they presumably test some
small fraction of the modules.
And then, if those
modules pass the test,
which take several
months to conduct--
and that's why there's a large
barrier for module innovation--
but if they pass
those tests, then they
assume that every module-- yes.
So there are a series
of, I would say,
definitions of what
constitutes a major alteration
to the process.
So if you majorly
alter your process,
then you have to get
your module recertified.
But if you stay
within those bounds,
then you can continue selling
under the old certification.
It's not too
dissimilar to the way
our food is tested by the FDA.
It's not every single hamburger.
It's a spot test.
In this particular case, these
are examples of the newest
technologies to
come off the line,
and you get a couple
of chances to pass.
If you fail the first one,
it's not the end of the world.
It just means that you
have to pass the next time
or else you have a
stain on your record.
And many of the companies
now have their own facilities
to do these tests in-house.
They still send them out
to the certified testing
bodies that are independent to
get the final seal of approval.
But they know fairly well
before they send them out,
are we going to pass or not?
In the early days
it was-- you always
had to hold on to the
seat of your pants
because you never
quite knew what
was going to happen when
the test results came back.
But now it's much better,
much more predictable.
And my favorite test out
of all the ones in there--
there are a number, if you
imagine a dozen to 20 tests,
from illuminating it and
measuring the power output.
One of my favorite tests
involves a hail gun.
So in a similar manner to
how the FAA tests windshields
of planes and plane engines
by shooting frozen chickens
or turkeys at them, in
this particular case,
we're shooting frozen balls
of water at the modules
and seeing if they crack.
That's one of the ones.
You can envision, as
well, an immersion test
underwater combined with
bending to see if there's
any failure in the module.
So they are tested
quite extensively using
these protocols.
And the objective is to
ensure quality and safety
to the consumer.
AUDIENCE: What's
the top right test?
PROFESSOR: This top right?
Oh, top right over here?
This is a mechanical loading
test, what it appears to be,
where you just exert
what is typically--
that's what it appears to
be in this particular case.
I could be wrong.
But my understanding is that
this module is constrained
on the edges right now and
that there's a load being
pushed down in the center.
You could also envision
a sandbag test where
you load physical sandbags.
There are a variety of
different types and variants.
Yep.
OK.
So that comes from the
First Solar spec sheet.
Describe the differences between
various types of PV systems.
Since we're running
short on time,
this is a bit of
a repeat from what
we talked about the very
first day in class--
the non-tracking, the tracking.
So I'm going to fly through that
into grid-tied and stand-alone.
So grid-tied and
stand-alone systems
is very straightforward.
If you have a system
that is tied to the grid,
somehow it has to be able
to interface with the grid.
Let me go to that in a second.
Here.
So if you're having
a grid-tied system,
that means that your house
or solar array, whatever
it is that's producing
the electricity,
has to be tied to the grid
and interface with it.
Since the electricity
is alternating current,
there has to be a
device to convert
the direct current power
into alternating current.
And that's called the inverter.
We've already touched upon that
a few times over today's class.
And these objects range in size.
For the ones in the
house, you could
find inverters that
are about yea big that
can handle a few kilowatts.
The ones that are handling
these large solar field
installations, or
segments thereof--
let me find a large
solar field installation.
Here we go.
Here are some pictures of large
solar field installations.
This is a road.
These little green
dots are trees.
That's a big field
installation right there.
Those inverters are
warehouse-- can be much larger
sized than the smaller ones
that you'd find in your house.
And so, listing the major
balance of system components,
the PV array would be connected
to the grid by an inverter.
The excess power would be
sent to the grid, causing
the meters to spin
backward, which
is a very gratifying
observation from a homeowner's
point of view or, at the
very least, a rate payer,
utility payer's point of view.
The act of sending the
power back to the grid
is a bit of free riding because
I'm not paying for the grid.
I'm a consumer, but I'm getting
credit for the electricity
that I put back in the grid.
But I'm not helping to
maintain the grid, necessarily.
I'm paying some transmission
and distribution costs
on my utility bill, but that's
essentially the same cost
that everyone else is paying.
Utility companies have begun
getting wise about that
and have begun
leveraging surcharges
based on the input
of solar electricity
into the grid, which I now pay.
So I'm no longer a free rider.
I was for a little bit.
So, mounted onto the
roof or the ground.
If you mount the
solar panels, you
need racking and
framing materials.
That's also balance of systems.
OK.
So.
Check.
You typically have, as
well, a circuit breaker,
or just a very simple lever
that disconnects the solar panel
from the grid.
Why is that important?
The utility companies know
that, on my house in Cambridge,
there's a solar array
and that that array
is connected to the grid.
Let's imagine a tree
falls on the power lines
during the next storm,
and the utility crew
has to go out there to
repair it during the day.
They know that, although the
rest of the grid is down,
there's that one little power
center on my house that's
injecting power into the grid.
And so they'll come
along to my house,
disconnect the solar
panels from the grid.
They'll go to my neighbors,
disconnect theirs as well.
Go to the person across
the street who also has
solar panels, disconnect them.
Then go to work on
the utility line.
So that's why the
external circuit
breaker is very important.
Back to inverters.
Modern efficiencies of
the inverter component
range between 94%
and 97% typical.
Record inverter efficiencies up
to 99% have been demonstrated.
And they all have what's
called maximum power point
tracking, which means that
they will be able to sense what
the combined output is
of the array on your roof
and adjust the
resistance in the circuit
to match the
maximum power point.
And that way you're producing
the maximum amount of power
that you could be, potentially,
under any given illumination
condition.
So a lot of fancy electronics
goes into the inverter.
I really have to give them a
lot of respect in that regard.
Typically five to seven, maybe
even 10-year manufacturer
warranty.
And the mounting
methods-- we talked
about mounting and racking.
This type was fairly common
in the early days of solar
where you'd have these field
installations, especially built
on hills in California.
I would say most common now is
really just mounting directly
on a roof-- oftentimes, flat.
For large field installations,
one-axis trackers
are very common nowadays.
Tracking as a function
of time of day
and then manually
adjusting the entire array
for season, if need be.
So the grid-tied systems
causing meters to spin backward.
Again, very gratifying.
And this is an example
of my utility bill, where
you have a balance
of $163 negative,
so they're giving me credit
over the course of a year.
In the winter time-- this was an
example of a month in December
when a lot of snow
happened and the panels
were covered for quite a
while, or at least partially
shaded by the snow for a while.
And we drew power from the
grid on net that month.
But on all the other months
we, on net, produced power.
And negative numbers aren't
shown in the scale here.
But if they were shown,
you'd see probably
greater negative value
in the summertime when
others were producing a lot of
power in the summer-- more sun.
And at the end of the year,
they draw a line at the bottom.
And they say, did
you owe us money?
No?
All right, great.
If we owed you
money-- tough luck.
If we're zero, then
everybody's happy.
So we typically produce
more electricity
than we consume in our house.
And that's an example of what
happens on a practical level.
Off-grid grid PV systems,
just ever so briefly.
So let's imagine that you're
running some illicit business,
and you want to be off-grid.
Or let's imagine that-- instead,
a more realistic example,
let's say that you're
afraid of the next power
outage, of being out of power
for the next 7 to 10 days
after the storm passes
through your house.
And you want to isolate yourself
from the grid, if need be.
You would want to have
a charge controller that
would be able to distribute
the power to the DC loads,
or to batteries to store
them, and then the inverter,
going through the AC loads
or to the grid thereafter.
So it is possible to architect a
system that is semi-autonomous.
But it does require more
components and more cost.
And I just wanted to emphasize
one thing as we close up.
Life is really good as
an installer right now.
If we flashed back to
four or five years ago,
life would have been really
good as a solar panel producer,
especially if you were involved
in the feedstock industry.
But now the prices
of modules have
been severely squeezed
by low-cost competition
from overseas.
And the pricing of modules is
around $1.03 per watt peak.
This is some of
lowest price modules
that are out there right now.
And the price of installing
the system on your roof here
in the US is around $5.20.
Who's pocketing the $4.20?
Who gets to keep that money?
Is it the installer or
the module producer?
AUDIENCE: The installer.
PROFESSOR: It's got
to be the installer.
Right?
And who's suffering right
now in the industry?
No matter where you
are-- US, China, Germany.
Who's suffering right now?
The module producers.
The people manufacturing
this stuff right here.
All right.
Which brings me to my
current topic of the day.
Everybody picked up
this one right here,
this Greentech Media article?
This is really current.
November 8, that
was two days ago.
Eric Wesoff.
He's higher up there
in Greentech Media.
And he's writing about
the China-US trade
war that's evolving pitting--
within the US-- pitting
the module manufacturers
against the installers.
So the installers,
these guys who
are pocketing a lot
of money right now,
are saying no, no, no, no.
Let the Chinese modules come in.
It's great.
It keeps our costs low.
The folks who are manufacturing
the modules, on the other hand,
are saying, well, wait a second.
They got unfair treatment
by their government.
And the Chinese module
manufacturers, in turn,
are saying, well, it's not only
us who are getting subsidies
from the government.
Look at yourselves.
You got subsidies, too.
And US manufacturers
say, well, you
got more subsidies than we did.
So it's evolving into a little
bit of a complex situation.
There are some people trying
to cut through all of that
and say, with very simplistic
messages, free trade.
Or certain other people saying,
made in USA is important.
Or other people
saying, this isn't
fair for one reason or another.
But it's important
to really understand
the complexity of what's
going on in the context
of a dynamically
changing market.
The market is
changing quite a lot.
In the past, the module prices--
and I say past, recent past,
as in a year ago-- module
prices were upwards of $2.50,
$3.00 per watt peak.
It's only in the oversupply
condition created within
the last year and a half where
the module prices have dropped
precipitously down to $1.00.
And that happens when you're
in an oversupply condition,
whereas these
installation prices really
haven't budged too much.
They're enjoying the fact that
it's in an oversupply condition
and there's still a
market for the modules.
So it's complex.
We'll explore some
of the complex issues
in our next few classes, and
we'll dive into that in detail.
I'll leave, for you to study on
your own, life cycle analysis.
It's very important.
Life cycle analysis--
in a nutshell,
it really depends on what you
consider in your analysis,
where you draw the box.
And at the end of the
day, module recycling
is going to be important
as well for determining
the ultimate impact, both in
terms of CO2 impact, energy
payback, and environmental
impact of PV in the long run.
So I'll leave you
with those thoughts.
And we'll see us on Tuesday.